we've got a lockdown coming again i'm so
mad about this lockdown i'm so depressed
i can't do another lockdown we've grown
this show has grown tremendously we've
made a lot of fun [ __ ]
we've had a lot of great episodes here
but i'm running out of stuff to talk
about i need to leave my [ __ ] house
i need to get out there and have
experiences with human beings
and i just this lockdown this draconi
i mean the news every day now is like
every news article now is like everyone
you know has coveted
that's the article they're like everyone
you know has coveted and every nurse you
knew has
killed herself how do you feel what
did you go out the other night and have
meatloaf yeah
well there's nurses hanging themselves
now why
why because you had a meatloaf i had it
in a parking lot it doesn't matter
you knew the risks and now everyone has
covered and all the nurses are killing
themselves
in front of their children what but it's
their job
i mean shouldn't they just go to work
people are there there's one thing where
they go like this they go
they're they're putting there's a
hospital in el paso texas where
our nurse goes we have a a room called
the pit
where we let all the covered patients
die i'm like why is that
happening why are we doing that
why is that allowed everybody's like i
feel so bad have you read the article
about the pit
and i'm like i want to know why there is
a pit
why are we putting people in a pit can
anyone explain that
you went out in that tuna tartare now
they're throwing human beings in the pit
in el paso what what
i don't want that
i'm losing it folks i'm losing it i just
took ben to a bentley dealership i don't
have the money to buy a bentley those
cars are
three hundred thousand dollars thank god
and i don't have credit i can't do
anything but
we just walked around a bentley
dealership thank god it was closed
but i'm losing my mind here because i
want to buy a bentley and drive it
through the er at cedar sinai
i want to i want to drive my bentley
through the pit
give everybody a glimpse of a nice car
before the end
it's tragic i know this shit's real it's
[ __ ] hard it's horrible reading these
stories
people facetiming their loved ones at
the end how hot how horrible is that
face time doesn't even work
you got your last words and they're
being they're freezing
you're trying to connect to the wi-fi
you're trying to hey can you connect me
to the wi-fi in the pit
the wi-fi in the pit is not good i'm
trying to talk to my mother
ma i'm in the pit
you shouldn't have gone out to dinner
last night you selfish [ __ ]
what i froze i said kant i called you a
[ __ ]
i mean what are we doing here oh man
it's tragic and it's real it's horrible
it's so sad people have like they got to
go on
they got to go on facetime to say
goodbye to their [ __ ] families
let the family in if i go from coven i
want my family
in that room getting sick with me
no face time i want my boomer father to
walk in there
maskless and get sick
i'm having a party in two days i feel
like an idiot
it's gonna be outside but that doesn't
[ __ ] matter
you know i think people are gonna try to
social distance i mean if the nelk boys
come i don't know how much social
distancing there's gonna be
they're just gonna go around and lick
people's faces like the bushwhackers
remember the that tag team and wwf what
my listeners do
and they would grab your face and lick
you when you when you were just there
and it was great and that's what the nel
kids are gonna do
steve will do it he's gonna run around
licking people's faces if they come
i just don't know i'm trying to laugh
and all the news it's so bad
i don't even know what's good now my
friend vanessa i'm the godfather to her
child
i'm like is it covered that bad she's
like not really but she's a sociopath
i mean she's a nurse but she's like
nurse ratchet
[Laughter]
you know she goes i gotta go to work
tomorrow and i hate the liver patients
i'm like what she goes i hate him she
goes when a heroin addict gets a new
liver they're real
uh she goes they're real paranoid and
anxious and they're not fun to deal with
i'm like
why are we giving heroin addicts new
livers
i'm confused about everything i just
need to buy a bentley
i just need to buy a gown on the cover
of vogue
to break out of the prayer i don't like
being a man no more
well you buy a moo moo like the rest of
us because we're broke
i only want a gown like harris styles is
wearing
i wear lane bryant tom we have nothing
in this house
i have three pairs of jeans and they're
all elastic band
i have three dresses and the last one i
wore was when we had to go to court for
your accident
i want i want a christian to your gown
what is wrong with these people scandal
sounds like these people are out of
their minds
they're like they're destroying
masculine how about they're destroying
masculinity by no one has a job
how about that how about they're
destroying masculinity no one can go to
work
they're not destroying masculinity
because there's a dude in ohio right now
that's like i want to get gucci
[ __ ] croc sandals and walk around
in a caftan and wear big [ __ ] chanel
sunglasses and palm springs
destroy masculine nobody can provide for
their family that used to be masculinity
providing for your family
i just love a guy like literally sitting
there with his wife and going
i don't feel i feel like i'm in a prison
of gender
and she goes i understand that but you
can't afford
to go buy a gown that this boy band
member wore on the cover of vogue
it's expensive john it's very expensive
and he's like you don't understand my
whole life
i felt like one thing and i was another
thing she goes i don't care what you
[ __ ] feel like
but you go to pay less and get some
pumps
and you go to [ __ ] get a cheap dress
from the goodwill
because you don't got no scratch john
all day we got to do the destruction of
masculinity and all these guys from long
island are getting on board about you
know the guys that have never served in
a war
and yet their their their [ __ ]
facebook profile picture is semper fi
right they're they're they're a military
adjacent
everyone in long island has nine flags
on their lawn they've never served one
day
they've never even helped an old person
cross the street let alone
served anybody they've never served
anything except they've served
themselves a drink
that's all they've ever served and
they're getting online they're like
thank god candace is calling out these
[ __ ] [ __ ]
trying to make me wear a [ __ ] dress
go to work you can't do that
because everybody's in the pit we are uh
all these hospitals we've had nine
months to get ready for the second wave
why is there no why is there no
preparedness
there's been eight m we knew the second
wave was coming
we knew it was coming it's like if
you're in the ocean and one wave knocks
you down
you stand up and you go oh you know what
i bet another wave is coming
and it's gonna hit me the same way maybe
even worse if you keep getting knocked
down by the same wave and you see kids
that are keep getting knocked down by
the same wave
there's a term for that it's called
drowning
and they need to be taken out by a
lifeguard but if you're an adult
you should have some semblance like why
have we not prepared for this
nobody's getting nobody's prepared i
don't understand
can someone help me here why are we
still throwing bodies in a pit
oh god i mean it's crazy
there's all these nurses that are on
facebook and the nurse will be like this
the nurse goes
i can't go on like this today i came in
and they didn't have any ppe i had to
wear the skin of someone who died
last night they fashioned a mask out of
their face
i'm walking around with someone else's
face on and we're just thro
we can't even treat any of these people
we're putting them up we're stacking
bodies in the parking lot and lighting
them on fire
and i go okay hold on a minute didn't we
know this was coming a little bit
wasn't that the differential here wasn't
the differential that we were gonna
prepare a little bit for this one
well the hospital decided that we
weren't
does no one have money are there no
resources is there's no tax base i get
it maybe that's the problem
everyone's talking about the relief bill
that's like not coming if i see by the
way and i love
comedy and i mean how many how many
times i got to say that
and i and ben just looks at me like we
know that that's not true because as
soon as i say that i then i'm going to
go off on this rant where i
like disparage everything about it but i
understand it's important to save like
independent venues i get it that's my
life
i'm not i'm not saying that but let's if
i see
one more time save our stages
if i see that one more time two things
down on the news feed after someone's
talking about something called the pit
where they're just throwing bodies and
throwing people in a room to die in el
paso
by the way does that have anything to do
with corona or is that just the way the
el paso hospital works
they go we've had the pit forever we
just we
we put you in the pit if you look even
slightly sick you go in the pit
and if you get out of it you get out of
it i mean what's next are going to come
out and they're going to be like
there's a fight club of corona patients
we're making them fight it out for
ventilators
are you happy now are you happy we're
making people
fight each other and the winner gets a
ventilator
i'm like is there no planning has no one
done any planning
folks
i'm confused i'm genuinely
confused it's ravaging the nation now
and i guess it's ravaging the small town
hospitals because
the larger cities have more of a tax
base
say what you want about these satanic
pedophiles but some of them pay taxes